und erzähl mal ein bisschen ab Matthias
Maurer unser Mann im All heute Live und
ganz irdisch hier bei uns im Studio und
was er alles erlebt hat da oben das
wollen wir uns jetzt erstmal anschauen
er ist unser Mann im All schwebte
monatelang über uns Matthias Maurer als
12ter deutscher durfte er das wovon
Millionen Träumen völlig losgelöst im
Weltall sein am 11 November 2021 wurde
für den 52-Jährigen der Lebenstraum war
nach jahrelanger Vorbereitung startete
Maurer als Astronaut der Europäischen
Weltraumorganisation Isa zur
Internationalen Raumstation ISS die
maurer-mission mehr als erfolgreich ob
zahlreiche Experimente in der Station
oder der Weltraumspaziergang für unseren
Matthias Maurer ein Kinderspiel doch
damit nicht genug auch diese Ehre wurde
Maurer zum Teil als erst vierter
deutscher der Geschichte kam er bei
Arbeiten außerhalb der ISS zum Einsatz
für Maurer natürlich gar kein Problem
nach mehreren schwerelosen Monaten ging
es für den gebürtigen Saarländer zurück
zu uns auf die Erde am 6 mai landete
Maurer wieder auf seinem Heimatplaneten
wasserte im Golf von Mexiko vor der
Küste Floridas Weltraumeinsatz der
preisverdächtig ist kein Wunder dass
Matthias Maurer Ende September mit dem
Bundesverdienstkreuz ausgezeichnet wurde
und das mehr als verdient
und jetzt bei uns bei Bild live Matthias
Maurer Astronaut herzlich willkommen
hier im Studio ja seit einigen Wochen
wieder auf der Erde zurück und jetzt
wissen wir was wir im Moment alles für
Krisen haben wollen sie am liebsten
wieder weg absolut als ich gestartet bin
im letzten Jahr im 11 November da war
die Welt noch in Ordnung und ich hätte
eigentlich ganz gerne wieder diese Welt
die ich damals verlassen habe und nicht
dieses Chaos was wir jetzt haben also
sie würden heute wieder los wenn Sie
heute gefragt würden ich bin heute
wieder zack wieder weg natürlich aber
ich wünsche mir natürlich auch hier für
den Planeten Erde dass wir wieder die
Bedingungen haben die wir vor diesem
Flug ist das eigentlich da oben spricht
man über sowas mit seinen Kollegen redet
man über die Krisen die ist gerade auf
der Erde gibt die man teilweise ja sogar
sehen kann von oben man kann Feuer sehen
und ähnliche Kriege war auch erkennen
haben Sie darüber gesprochen in der Zeit
ja also definitiv wir sind ja oben auch
dann mit dem Internet verbunden haben
die Nachrichten oben genauso aktuell wie
wir hier unten und wir alle hatten das
mitverfolgt als sich diese Spannungen
aufgebaut haben aber keiner von uns hat
wirklich geglaubt am 24 sechsten Februar
dass da wirklich ein Krieg losgeht in
Europa wir dachten aus diesen Zeiten
sind wir lange schon raus wir haben mit
dem Modelle iss gezeigt dass man durch
friedliche Kooperationen viel erreichen
kann und für uns ist eine richtig in der
Welt zusammengebrochen als wir erfahren
mussten da ist Krieg auf der Erde aber
ist das nicht irre dass man im Weltall
dort auch so engem Raum auch jetzt
gerade noch miteinander unterwegs ist
das ist ein schönes Zeichen aber auf der
Welt ist man völlig unterschiedlicher
Meinung gerade und jetzt sitzen sie
sozusagen mit dem russischen Kollegen
nebeneinander dort auf engstem Raum das
ist doch eigentlich irre dass das
funktionieren soll und muss ja also in
erster Linie sind wir dort oben sieben
Menschen sieben Menschen die lange
trainiert haben die die gleiche Vision
haben wir möchten in den Weltraum
fliegen wir möchten erkunden was es dort
draußen gibt weil es gibt ganz wichtige
Fragestellungen die wir lösen wollen und
nur in zweiter oder dritter Linie sind
wir ein Deutscher ein Amerikaner ein
Russe und das Vertrauen was wir oben
aufeinander haben das muss 100 Prozent
sein ansonsten kann ich nicht aus der
Raumstation aussteigen und einen
wichtigen Einsatz durchführen wenn da
etwas passiert gibt es nur einen
Menschen der mit mir auch draußen dabei
ist und es mir egal ob der einen
russischen Pass hat oder ein
amerikanischen Pass hat da hängt mein
Leben von dieser zweiten Person ab und
wir als Astronauten haben gelernt unser
Raumschiff funktioniert nur durch
Vertrauen und Zusammenarbeit und wenn
wir von oben runterschauen auf die Erde
dann ist die Erde für uns auch nur ein
Raumschiff in ganz großes mit 8
Milliarden Astronauten und für uns ist
es eigentlich klar die Herausforderungen
der Erde können wir nur lösen wenn alle
acht Milliarden Astronauten
zusammenarbeiten und schwierig ja sie
haben auch gesagt gerade es geht
natürlich auch darum im All eben ja
Fragen zu lösen Antworten zu finden auf
Fragen die die Menschheit schon auch
sehr lange bewegen eine Frage ist
natürlich auch die nach außerirdischem
Leben wenn man jetzt die ganze Zeit da
oben ist zwischen diesen Sternen kann
man da ein bisschen näher dran fängt man
da ein bisschen mehr an
glauben wir können doch hier eigentlich
nicht alleine sein ja also ich bin
Wissenschaftler ich denke jetzt nicht
einfach da da fliegen irgendwelche
grünen Wesen rum und ich habe Angst vor
denen sondern
wir wissen es gibt 100 Milliarden
Galaxien und jede Galaxie hat pi mal
Daumen 100 Milliarden noch mal
Sonnensysteme die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass es noch mal ein Sonnensystem gibt
ähnlich wie unsere mit einer Erde mit
Bedingungen die Leben ermöglichen es so
viel größer als ein Sex am Lotto zu
haben ich habe zwar noch nie ins Sechser
gewonnen aber es gibt ja mal wieder
welche also für mich ist es eigentlich
gesetzt dass es dort draußen eine zweite
Erde gibt ob dort dann das Leben
entstanden ist wie auf unserer Erde ist
die große Frage gibt es Pflanzen gibt es
kleine Tierchen gibt es einzeln wenn wir
das noch miterleben unsere Generation
werden wir das noch noch schaffen dass
wir sehen okay wir können vielleicht
auch kommunizieren mit anderen lesen wir
können ja leider nur mit
Lichtgeschwindigkeit kommunizieren das
heißt wir können eigentlich nur die
Planetensystemen unserer Nähe erreichen
und ich denke das Leben was es da
draußen gibt das ist vermutlich so weit
weg dass wir damit zu unseren Zeiten mit
der jetzigen Technologie nicht
kommunizieren können und ich finde es
auch ganz spannend wenn es eine
Zivilisation draußen gibt die dann
vielleicht 1000 Jahre vor uns gestartet
ist wo ist die denn schon und wenn die
uns anschauen was denken die von uns
Außerirdischen
den Fuß auf den Mars setzen sozusagen
werden wir das erleben
ja also ich werde vom Sofa auserleben
die esaplan 2030 möchten wir den ersten
Europäer die erste Europäerin auf dem
Mond haben 20 40 rum das finde ich jetzt
ein bisschen sportlich vermutlich in den
40er Jahren möchten wir die erste
Europäerin den ersten Europäer auf dem
Mars haben und das sind spannende Zeiten
ich hoffe ein Kapitel 1 Mond darf ich
nur aktiv mitwirken selbst vielleicht
auch dorthin fliegen oh Maß ist
wahrscheinlich etwas für die Generation
der heute dann ganz jungen Kinder die
vielleicht heute zuhören und begeistert
sind und die dann in Zukunft dann unsere
Geschichten erzählen also die Menschheit
war ja schon mal auf dem Mond was er
hofft man sich denn jetzt noch mal von
einem Trip dahin was würden Sie sich
davon erhoffen da jetzt irgendwie noch
mal zu finden Montag hat man damals
gemacht als Wettrennen um zu zeigen hier
USA ist besser ein besseres System als
sie so wird Union und es war wenig auf
Wissenschaft fokussiert man hatte bei
dem letzten Flug zwar ein
Wissenschaftler dabei aber jetzt möchte
man hinfliegen um viele
wissenschaftliche Fragen zu lösen im
Mond gibt es das weiß man mittlerweile
es gibt wassereisen ganz tiefen Grad
dann in der Pole Region das sind
Ressourcen da könnte ich eine Station
aufbauen ähnlich wie heute in der
Antarktis wo Forscher sind mit dem
Wassereis kann ich natürlich Trinkwasser
herstellen das Wasser kann ich
aufspalten in Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff
also kann ich auch Atemluft erzeugen
Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff ist aber auch
Raketentreibstoff das heißt ich kann auf
dem Mund einmal volltanken und zum Mars
durchstarten und ich kann dieses
Wassereis das ist ganz spannend das ist
ja irgendwann mal auf dem Mond gelandet
und das ist zur gleichen Zeit auf dem
Mond eingeschlagen als auch Kometen
Asteroiden Wasser auf die Erde gebracht
haben so und wenn wir jetzt überlegen
wie ist das Leben auf der Erde gestartet
das kam aus dem All hat eingebracht mit
solchen gefrorenen Wasserreserven und
das heißt auf dem Mond könnten wir in
diesem Eis vielleicht noch Spuren finden
die uns erklären wie das Leben auf der
Erde entstanden ist eventuell auch mit
Mikroben kleine Bakterien ähnliches sehr
spannend beneide ich sie um mindestens
eins ja wirklich und vor allen Dingen
ihren Blick auf uns da auf unsere Erde
auf die schöne Erde und sie haben uns
ganz besondere Fotos mitgebracht auf die
wir einmal gemeinsam schauen können der
ganz besondere Blick von ganz oben auf
unsere Erde und vielleicht können wir
ein paar dieser Fotos einmal zeigen und
sie erläutern einfach mal was wir hier
sehen also hier sehen wir einen Blick
auf die Erdatmosphäre und man sieht ganz
schön dieses Farbenspektrum ist ähnlich
wie im Physikunterricht wenn das Licht
auf gespalten wird und genauso sieht es
aus dem Weltraum aus das haben sie
gemacht aus dem Fenster sozusagen aus
dem russischen Fenster weil dieses
russische Fenster hat eine andere
Beschichtung als unser kupola Fenster
dort wir sollen ja kein Sonnenbrand oben
bekommen in dem starken Sonnenlicht
deswegen sind der andere Filter drauf
und hier dieses Bild zeigt einmal wie
schön wie dünn auch diese Schicht ist um
die Erde rum und alles was da so blau
und rot dargestellt ist dort es Leben
möglich außerhalb wo schwarzes es Leben
nicht möglich und das finde ich so
faszinierend es gibt kein Plan B wir
haben nur unsere einzigen Planeten Erde
und auf der Erde auch nur diesen dünnen
Saum und je nachdem wie die Sonne steht
sieht dieser saumach aus wie eine
Seifenblase und ja ganz schnell platzen
könnte ja also die wird natürlich nicht
platzen die stabil hat der erste Blick
wir müssen so viel sanfter mit unseren
Planeten umgeben weil das ist das
Einzige was wir haben wo wir leben
können dass die Erde sich verändert
sieht man auch an anderen Bildern die
sie mitgebracht haben zum Beispiel aus
Patagonien da sieht man auch die
Eisberge natürlich auch ein sehr sehr
kritischer Punkt wie fühlt sich das an
wenn man das von oben so sieht was denkt
man dabei ja also hier das ist Feuerland
zu sehen auch noch mal der dünne Schweif
oben der Saum die Atmosphäre ich war
dort auch als Student unterwegs und habe
dort die Gletscher gesehen die dann dort
auf dem Boden entlang rutschen und die
ist sehr sehr mächtig sind und die sind
jetzt mittlerweile weniger mächtig
geworden das heißt da erkennt man den
Klimawandel und das gibt mir dann schon
sehr viel zu ich sage okay wir Menschen
wir richten diesen Planeten
ich will nicht sagen zugrunde aber wir
verändern ihn so nachhaltig wir müssen
nachhaltiger denken auch damit die
nächsten Generationen noch genauso
Lebenschance haben auf unserem Planeten
wie wir dazu passt auch das Foto vom
Korallenriff was sie gemacht haben
können wir auch noch mal drauf schauen
also auch da geht es um die Veränderung
unserer Erde um die Veränderung unserer
Meere unseres Planeten ja das ist eine
Insel auf den Bahamas und was da so ein
hellem türkisblau dargestellt ist im
Innenraum das ist so
korallenbereiche und Korallen sind ja
ganz ganz wichtig
für die Lebensmittelkette also dort
leben viele kleine Lebewesen die dann
Nahrungsmittel sind für die größeren
Lebewesen und die dann irgendwann zu
fischen werden die wir dann essen bei
uns auf dem Küchentisch und das heißt
wenn dort eine Veränderung einsetzt dann
merken wir das später auch bei uns
und wir wissen jetzt durch die Erwärmung
der Meere sterben diese Korallen ab und
das können wir sehen aus dem Weltraum
kurz nachdem ich oben weggeflogen bin
waren enorme Temperaturen in der Gegend
von Australien und die Korallen sahen
damals nicht mehr so aus als im Weltraum
sondern waren total
beweisgeblichen und während meines
Trainings hatte ich auch sage ich mal
die schöne Gelegenheit unter Wasser zu
tauchen vor Florida habe ich dann 16
Tage unter Wasser gelebt mit dem Ziel
dann den Maß zu erkunden das war
wirklich so eine Übung aber wir haben
damals auch parallel dazu Wissenschaft
gemacht und haben abgestorbene
Korallenbänke wieder aufgeforstet um
sozusagen hier zu sehen was kann die
Wissenschaft dazu beitragen diese
Korallen zu retten ganz wahnsinnig
spannend wir könnten noch Stunden mit
Ihnen reden Herr Maurer leider geht uns
die Zeit ein bisschen außer wir danken
Ihnen sehr dass sie hier waren dass sie
diese Eindrücke mit uns geteilt haben
danke schön
[Musik]